The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, let's finish
up new material today, new
material Monday, and then
we're done with
the kinetics unit.
So, we're going to talk about
temperature, collision theory,
and activated complex
theory today.
So on the first day, we talked
about kinetics, we talked
about factors affecting the
rates, and this was in your
handout on that first lecture,
but just to kind of review for
a minute what we have
talked about so far
and where we're going.
So these are some of the things
we came up with are
factors affecting the
rates of reaction.
People said mechanism affects
the rate of reaction, so we
talked about mechanism.
Concentration of material,
nature of material -- that
pretty much fits in
in every lecture.
We've been talking some about
that, say, if it's first order
or second order, if you have a
concentration term in there,
or if you don't have a
concentration term.
The nature of the material,
we're going to talk more about
that today.
Temperature is going to be the
number one topic for today,
and on Monday the number one
topic is the use of catalysts
to speed up reactions.
So, by Monday we'll be
done with this list.
So, what about temperature.
So temperature, when I said
what affects the rate of
reaction, temperature was one of
the things that you yelled
out at me, and that's very much
true, it has one of the
biggest effects on the
rate of reactions.
So when we were talking about
the gas phase, there was an
observation made that the
reaction rates tend to
increase as the temperature
increases.
And most of you can think about
this and are aware of
it, and today we're going
to talk more about the
quantitative affect of this,
how much does the rate of a
reaction increase when the
temperature increases, how do
you know what equation
do you use.
So, this idea has been
around for awhile.
So in 1889, Arrhenius plotted
rate constants versus
temperature, and he found that
if he plotted the natural log
of those rate constants versus
inverse temperature, then he
would get a straight line.
So let's look at the
plot that he had.
So, he found that if he plotted
natural log of the
rate constants versus 1 over
temperature, so units or
kelvin to the minus 1, that
he got a straight line.
Which means that the rate
constants are varying
exponentially with inverse
temperature.
So you have to use a natural log
to get a straight line, if
you don't use natural log,
you wouldn't get a
straight line here.
So, let's look at some of these
terms that we have here,
and here's our equation for the
straight line, the natural
log of k equals minus e a -- e
a is activation energy, which
we're going to talk a lot about
today -- over r t, r is
our friend the gas constant,
and t is temperature, plus
natural log of a.
So what is a?
A is called factor a or
sometimes it's called
pre-exponential factor, and had
has the same units as k, k
being the rate constant.
So, let's think about this
equation and this plot, and
about factor A and this other
term, activation energy.
So, factor A and activation
energy depend on the reaction
being studied.
So, it depends on the nature
of the materials involved.
So I said we'd talk again about
nature of the material.
So one kind of reaction's going
to have one activation
energy, another one will
have a different one.
So, let's think about
this term, factor
A. What is it exactly?
Do you think it would be
temperature dependent?
What do you think?
How many people think
yes, it would
be temperature dependent?
How many people think no?
Some people are not
going to commit.
The answer is no.
So, let's think about
what factor A is.
So, factor A is the rate
constant at some really,
really large temperature.
So, if we look at this plot,
the natural log of k equals
the natural log of A, or
k equals A if you're
along this axis here.
If you're along that axis
here, that's at zero, so
that's when 1 over temperature
equals zero, then the rate
constant equals factor A. What
would be true about the
temperature for 1 over
temperature to equal zero?
Very big.
So, at the biggest, hugest
temperature you can imagine,
the rate constant's going to
equal A. And so, factor A
depends on the nature of the
material being studied and you
would have to determine
what that value is.
But it's definitely not
temperature dependent.
It's the value of the rate
constant at an enormous
temperature.
So, what about activation
energy?
Do you think that's temperature
dependent?
Why don't you tell me
what you think.
All right, let's take
10 more seconds.
All right, so I'd like you
to discuss this amongst
yourselves and see whether
you're happy with this answer.
All right, go ahead
and vote again.
All right, 10 more seconds.
And the correct answer is?
So, I think most of you will
remember this answer.
So the activation energy is
not temperature dependent.
You can calculate what the
activation energy is by
plotting the rate constants
versus 1 over temperature, and
then you get it from the
slope of the line.
So, activation energy depends on
the nature of the material,
but it isn't temperature
dependent.
So, we're going to talk a lot
more about that today.
Before we leave this, I just
want to say one thing about a
clicker question.
So, at the end of last time, we
had our first repeat winner
for a clicker competition.
So, we thought that we might
have an opportunity for
recitations to see if they can
-- if some other recitation
can get a second win.
So on Monday we're going to
have our final clicker
competition, and if somebody
else does tie, one section,
that we'll have a final one-time
clicker question
that'll be a run-off.
And whatever recitation wins, we
have special prizes for the
members of that recitation.
So that's on Monday.
So you may want to review
catalysis on Monday, if you
feel that you're in the running
for the grand champion
clicker recitation.
All right, so let's
go back to this.
So we found out that no,
activation energy is not
temperature dependent.
All right, so what are you going
to see on your equation
sheet on the final, you may
see a couple of different
forms that are all equivalent
to each other.
So here is the plot of
a straight line.
It will often be written with
just natural log of a and e a
over r t terms reversed.
So that's as a straight line,
and this is often what you see
for the Araneus equation.
You can also get rid of the
natural logs and have the term
here exponential, so you have
k equals factor A times e to
the minus, activation energy
divided by r t.
So, those are the equations,
they're all equivalent to each
other that you might see
on your equation sheet.
So, it's also true that
non-gases can exhibit this
kind of behavior, and let me
just give you one example of a
non-gas that exhibits this kind
of behavior and you tell
me what this is.
What is that?
Crickets.
So crickets exhibit Arrhenius
behavior.
They will chirp faster as the
temperature gets hotter.
So if you're out camping,
sometimes it can be in the
summer, it can be actually be
quite deafening, and you were
very happy to go back to the
city where you only have
ambulances and cars going, and
you don't have this incredible
racket at night.
You can actually calculate what
the temperature is by
counting the number of chirps
of the crickets and using a
little equation.
I think it's you count for 14
seconds and add 40 and that's
the temperature in fahrenheit
or something like that.
So, not only gases do this
kind of behavior.
All right, so activation energy,
we're going to be
talking a lot about
this today.
So, what is it exactly.
So let's think about two
molecules coming together.
So when two molecules come
together, you have this
bimolecular process going on,
but every time two molecules
come together, they're
not going to go
on and form a product.
You're only going to form a
product when those molecules
have a critical amount
of energy.
When they have the energy which
allows them to react,
that activation energy.
If they have enough energy when
they come together, they
will go on and form products.
So, that's what activation
energy is, it's this critical
amount of energy that they need
to react with each other.
All right, so let's just think
about what affects that
critical amount of energy, and
of course, temperature is
going to be involved.
So let's think about that.
So if we have fraction of
molecules on one side, and we
have kinetic energy down here,
let's think about how
temperature is involved
in this.
So, at a low temperature, the
fraction of molecules that are
going to have enough energy to
react is going to be less.
And let's think about at a
higher temperature, go like
this, so this is high
temperature, and we have low
temperature up here.
And then over here we would have
our activation energy,
the energy needed
for a reaction.
And you see, if you're at low
temperature, only a small
number of molecules are going
to have enough energy to
react, but if you're at higher
temperature, a large number of
molecules are going to have that
critical energy to react.
So, at low temperature, not
many can react, at higher
temperature, many more will have
that energy -- will be
able to overcome that activation
energy, will have
it and they can react.
So, temperature plays
a big role here.
So we can use this idea of
activation energy to predict a
rate constant.
Let's look at an example.
So, often people have sucrose
in their diet, and the
hydrolysis of sucrose will form
glucose and fructose as
part of this digestive
process.
And we can think about the
rates at which that would
happen in the body.
So normally, we're at 37
degrees, that's normal body
temperature, and we have the
observed rate constant for
that is 1 .
0 times 10 to the minus 3
per molar per second.
But what happens if your body
temperature is lowered, what
happens if it was at 35 degrees,
and to be able to
answer that question, you need
to know what the activation
energy is for this process,
and here it's 108
kilojoules per mole.
So, we want to ask the question,
what is the new rate
constant at 35 degrees?
So, we can take our Arrhenius
equations, and we can put a 1
by the rate constant for
temperature 1, and a 2 for the
rate constant at
temperature 2.
Now we can combine
these equations.
Natural log of a cancels out,
it's not temperature dependent
so it doesn't stay in here.
And so we can solve, we can
subtract these two, or that's
equivalent to dividing them,
and so natural log of rate
constant 2 over rate constant 1
equals minus the activation
energy over the gas constant
times this temperature term.
Does this look at
all familiar?
Does this look like some
other equation you
saw once upon a time?
Do you remember what that
equation was called?
Van't Hoff equation, right.
And there we were
comparing what
instead of rate constants?
Equilibrium constants, and
instead of e a, what term did
we have here?
Delta h, right.
And it's good you remember that
because we're going to
come back to that at the
end of today's class.
So, we can use this equation
and plug in the values.
We put in our activation energy,
and remember to pay
attention to units, because if
you're going to cancel your
joules with a gas constant, you
want to make sure you've
converted your kilojoules to
joules, and then we can plug
everything in and
solve for k 2.
So, here k 2 is 7 .
6 times 10 to the minus
4 per molar per
second, so it's slower.
And this is one reason why it's
really nice to have your
body temperature stay the
normal temperature.
If you get too cold, your body
processes, your enzymes are
not functioning, everything
is slowed down.
And if you get too hot, that's
not good either.
So you really want to maintain
it, and so for some of you who
come to MIT from warmer
climates, let me introduce you
to the L.L. Bean catalog, they
sell coats, they sell boots,
and all sorts of things.
So, this winter, when you come
back for IAP, or for the term,
you're well-prepared, and you
don't have to prove that it's
not good if your body
temperature
goes below 37 degrees.
All right, let's think about
what else this equation tells
us, and the other thing it tells
us is that if you have a
very large activation energy,
if this e a is a very, very
big number, that means that your
rate constants will be
very sensitive to temperature.
So if this is really, really
big, there's going to be a big
change in your rate constants
as temperature changes.
And keep that in mind,
we're going to come
back to that later.
So, what do you think happens
to the rate of an enzymatic
reaction at liquid nitrogen
temperatures?
We looked at going from 37
degrees to 35, liquid nitrogen
is pretty cold.
So, not a whole lot happens at
liquid nitrogen temperatures
as far as enzymes go, and I'll
just mention, so it slows way
down, that this is a trick that
I use in my research.
So we have crystals of enzymes,
and we can try to get
structures in particular states
by taking the crystals
that have enzyme in it, and
starting a reaction, and then
dunking the crystals in liquid
nitrogen to kind of stop it at
a particular stage, and then you
look at what the structure
looks like.
So that's one use.
So, we're going to also take a
look at other reactions, we
don't have any enzymes here,
but some other things, and
look at what happens when we
get things to be very cold.
[EXPERIMENTING]
So, Dr. Taylor is pouring out
some liquid nitrogen.
PROFESSOR: All right, so what
we're going to look at is a
reaction that we can see
pretty easily here.
Have any of you used glow sticks
before, maybe trick or
treating or some other point.
So basically, you may or may
not know how they work.
There's two compartments in
glow sticks that have two
different chemicals in them, and
they're trade secrets so
we can't put them
on the board.
But basically, what we have
here is a reaction.
A lot of reactions we know give
off heat, or they give
infrared light.
Here we have a reaction
that gives off
energy as visible light.
So would you call this an
endothermic or an exothermic
reaction here?
Yeah, so this is an exothermic
reaction.
So just as Professor Drennan was
talking about with slowing
down enzymatic reactions we can
think about if we can slow
down this reaction.
So, we're just going to put it
in the liquid nitrogen -- so,
keep an eye on this, we'll do
several controls of different
colors here.
So, see if an orange glow
stick works the same.
What we're looking to
see is if we can
slow down this reaction.
What would we see if we
slowed it down or even
if we stopped it?
Yeah, we're not going to
see anymore color.
So are you starting to see
color loss in this first
reaction here?
So, we'll try green,
and yellow.
So, it looks like this first
one might have stopped
already, you see there's
no color anymore here.
What would you expect if this
heated back up to room
temperature?
Yeah, so hopefully, if you just
keep your eye on this,
we'll continue on with the
lecturing, because I don't
know how long it will take for
it to warm back up the room
temperature.
But keep an eye and we'll see if
we get the temperature back
high enough to see
the glow again.
And since we do have a liquid
nitrogen here, it's too hard
to resist freezing a flower.
This has nothing to do with
kinetics -- we can't even try
that connection.
But we will be freeze
a flower.
OK, she will try making --
good catharsis pre-exam.
PROFESSOR: So, has
anyone had liquid
nitrogen applied to them?
It's used in doctor's offices,
if you want a little something
removed perhaps, put a little
liquid nitrogen
on and burn it off.
Good premed training for you.
I think we're pretty
frozen here.
So it looks the same, but
as you can see --
[INAUDIBLE] --
So I think that's all
we can do [LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So I actually heard
something interesting on NPR
about liquid nitrogen removing
warts and things like that,
and they were talking about how
there was something that
was actually better than liquid
nitrogen for doing that.
Did anyone hear the story about
what the thing was that
was better than liquid
nitrogen?
It was duct tape.
And so some scientists had
looked at what all the uses of
duct tape are.
And since most of you are
planning on being scientists
or engineers, duct tape will
probably be an important part
of your life in the future.
And so, duct tape worked better
than liquid nitrogen
for removing warts.
And they found that duct
tape worked really well
for a lot of things.
There was only one thing
they tried that it did
not work well for.
Anyone want to guess
what that was?
Repairing ducts, yes.
Not really good -- there were
many, many, many better ways
to repair ducts than with duct
tape, but I guess they decided
that calling it wart removal
tape was just not quite as
catchy as duct tape,
so it's still
referred to as duct tape.
OK, so when you lower the
temperature, things
tend to slow down.
But if molecules are going to
react, they need to have
enough energy, they need to have
a high enough temperature
to overcome this activation
energy.
So that critical amount.
So again, when the molecules
come together, and let's just
look at these for a minute, when
they're coming together
to react, and if they're going
to react, there needs to be
some energy associated with
this, because you're probably
going to have to break a bond,
and that's going to take
something, and then you
may have to form a
new bond, for example.
So there needs to be a critical
amount of energy, you
need to be able to overcome that
activation energy barrier
for the molecules to react.
So it always takes some energy
for things to react and so you
need to have enough energy.
And so, if those molecules have
that energy, they'll come
together, react, and you'll
form products.
If they don't have that energy,
they're just going to
go back to what they were,
unchanged reactants.
So you need to have sufficient
energy to overcome that
activation energy barrier.
So, this is just a little movie
that shows two molecules
coming together, and if they
have enough energy to react,
you will see a spark, and then
the molecules will react.
So, here we go.
Molecule in red, in
green, they're
checking each other out.
Do they have enough -- they had
enough energy, and they
reacted, and went
on to product.
All right, so let's talk about
this activation energy barrier
and these activated complexes.
OK, so in this example, you have
n o 2 plus c o, and they
can come together and
form n o plus c o 2.
And that's going to take some
amount of energy to react.
And so, I'm drawing something
that's called an activated
energy diagram, and we have
potential energy on one axis,
and on the other we have what's
called a reaction
coordinate.
And so, the reactants are going
to have a certain amount
of energy, so our reactants are
going to have some amount
of energy, and our products
will have
some amount of energy.
But even though in this case the
change, the products are
lower in energy, and you have
a delta e for the difference
between the reactants and the
products, they can't go
directly to products.
They have to overcome an
activation energy barrier.
So they have to overcome
some kind of barrier
before they can react.
So, only ones that can overcome
that barrier, that
have enough energy to overcome
this activation energy
barrier, so the activation
energy for the forward
reaction, only those will
be able to react.
There's also an activation
energy barrier for the reverse
reaction on this side.
So, if you go from products
to reactants, you have to
overcome that activation
energy barrier.
And up here, this is called the
activated complex, so you
have some kind of activated
complex or transition state,
so the molecules will come
together, they'll form some
kind of transition state
up here, and then
go down into products.
OK, so most of you are sort of
familiar with the concept, I
think, of this activation
energy, we've been talking
about it, but the idea of an
activation energy barrier, I
think is something that probably
all of you can
personally connect with.
So, for me, one of the things
that I find really hard to do
is get started writing
a long National
Institutes of Health grant.
They're about 25 pages long,
they're single spaced, font
11, and they have point 5
margins on every side of the
page, and it's really dense,
and it takes a long time to
sort of get going on that.
And so, there is deadlines, and
MIT is very particular,
you need to have it to the
Office of Sponsored Research
five full business days before
it's due at the National
Institutes of Health, and then
the Department needs
to sign off on it.
And I'll be looking at my
calendar and I have those
dates marked, and checking how
many days I have left, and
eventually, just like getting
started, it's like oh, there's
so much to do, I have to read
the literature, the new stuff
that's come out on my topic.
And I have to think about what
projects I'm going to do in
the future, and I have to write
about the progress that
I've made so far, which is not
really what I want it to be.
And so, I think a lot about how
-- it's just overwhelming.
But then eventually
something happens.
Either it's tremendous fear that
there's so few days left
and you just have to do it.
Sometimes it's going and getting
an enormous cup of
coffee and sitting down.
You know, people have been
known to sort of chain
themselves to their desk, like
they're not going to get to
get up until they've written the
introduction to the grant.
So, a lot you can connect
with this.
That any new thing you start,
there's some barrier that you
have to overcome to get
started with it.
And often once you're started
it's not that bad, and some of
you may be thinking, exam 1 was
a long time ago, I recall
there was a lot of material
on exam 1.
And it seems really scary.
But then the fact that I mention
the final exam over
and over in class is helping you
get that energy that you
need to overcome that activation
energy barrier and
start studying, because once you
start studying you go, Oh
yeah, I remember this,
this wasn't so bad.
So you just need to get over
that activation energy barrier
and you're all set.
So, molecules have to do the
same thing, and the ones that
have higher temperature have
an easier time getting over
that barrier.
So, here we can talk about
this general process.
We can look at the individual
numbers involved.
So in this particular case,
there's an activation energy
for the forward reaction of 132
kilojoules per mole, and
there is an activation energy
for the reverse reaction of
358 kilojoules per mole.
And there's also a delta e for
the reaction, which is this
line, from reactions to
products, which in this case
is minus 226 kilojoules
per mole.
So do you think this reaction is
endothermic or exothermic?
What do you think, exothermic
or endothermic?
It's exothermic, and if you look
back in your notes, we
talked a little bit about the
relationship between delta h
and delta e.
And they're actually
pretty similar.
A delta h usually equals delta
e plus a change in p v. So,
for gases it's about 1% or 2%
difference, and for solids,
there's really negligible
difference between
delta e and delta h.
So, they're pretty similar
types of values.
So, we can we can think about
what delta e really is, and so
delta e in terms of activation
energy is going to be equal to
the activation energy for the
forward reaction minus the
activation energy for the
reverse reaction.
And in this particular case,
we have 226 kilojoules per
mole is our delta e, and for our
forward reaction, we have
132 kilojoules per mole, and for
the reverse reaction, the
activation energy for the
reverse reaction is 358
kilojoules per mole, and so
these should all equal up to
each other.
And so, if you know two of
these values, you can
calculate the third.
And this is one of the equations
that you have to
memorize for the final, because
it has, its sort of a
conceptual thing that you need
to understand what this
diagram says, that this plus
that is equal to that, that
these all add up
to each other.
And if you have a negative value
here, that means it's an
exothermic reaction.
So, this delta e is a change
in internal energy of the
system, and you can determine
that value experimentally,
say, with a calorimetry
experiment.
OK, so let's keep this in mind
and go on and take a look at
how this connects back with some
other things that we have
already talked about
in this course.
So, for an elementary reaction,
and I think for all
of us, there's always
some activation
energy barrier to overcome.
There's always some positive
activation energy to overcome.
And because there's always
this activation energy to
overcome, increasing the
temperature is always going to
increase the rate of an
elementary reaction.
It's always going to make it
easier to get over that
activation energy barrier.
But for an overall reaction,
increasing the temperature may
not increase the rate
of the reaction.
So let's consider why
that would be true.
So, here is a reaction that
we've talked about before, we
talked about this proposed
mechanism where we have a fast
reversible step and a
slow second step.
So we learned last time that
we can write the rate of
product formation from the
second step, there are two
molecules of n o 2 being formed,
so we have 2 times k
2, the concentration
of n 2 o 2, and the
concentration of o 2.
But this is an intermediate, so
we need to solve for that
intermediate.
So, in this case, we have a fast
reversible first reaction
and a slow second reaction.
So this intermediate is going to
build up, and it's going to
be more or less an equilibrium
with the reactants, because
this is very fast, and only a
little bit of this is siphoned
off to make product, and so this
creates an equilibrium
type situation.
So why don't you solve this
intermediate for me, this is a
review from the last class.
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Very good.
So, we can solve for this,
equilibrium constant for the
first step, products over
reactants, and then if you
solved for this, the
intermediate here, which is
the product in the first step,
then it would be equal to k 1
times n o squared.
We can take that term and we can
we can plug it in, so over
here, we can substitute it into
this equation, and so we
have 2 k 2, big K 1 times
n o squared times o 2.
All right, so here
is our rate then.
And if you missed some of this,
this was in the notes
from before.
So now let's think about the
effect of temperature.
So, k 2 is an elementary rate
constant, and so its
temperature -- if you increase
the temperature,
its rate will increase.
So here again is our equation,
the activation energy is
always positive, there's always
positive, there's
always some barrier
to overcome.
So if you increase the
temperature, you're always
going to increase the
elementary rate.
Well, what about equilibrium
constant?
So we've talked about this back
in chemical equilibrium
that the effect of temperature
on the equilibrium constant
depends on whether the reaction
is endothermic or
exothermic.
And you told me before, the
equation, and that's the Van't
Hoff equation shown here.
And so look how similar
those equations are.
So for an elementary rate
constant, we had e a, and for
equilibrium constant, we're
talking about delta h.
So, if you have, here the
reaction is exothermic, and if
you increase the temperature
of an exothermic reaction,
what happens to k?
It decreases.
So, again, it would shift,
then, to the endothermic
direction, decreasing k.
So let's look at this then.
So we have in this k obs term,
we have an elementary rate
constant and an equilibrium
constant, so if you if you
increase the temperature, the
rate constant increases, but
the equilibrium constant
is going to decrease.
So, the magnitude of the
increase or decrease depends
on the size of the activation
energy or the size of delta h.
So for this particular example,
there's no way that
you would know this so I'm
telling you, that the
activation energy is a small
number, or you might be able
to look it up in your book,
and delta h is a very big
number and it's negative, it's
an exothermic reaction.
So if you have a very small
number for e a, that means
that the rate constant will
increase only a little bit,
it's not that sensitive to a
change in temperature, because
e a's a very small number.
But if delta h is a big number,
then the equilibrium
constant would decrease a lot
with temperature because this
is a big number here.
So in this particular example,
increasing the temperature
actually decreases the observed
rate, because delta h
is, in this particular example,
a much bigger thing.
So if you were given either
numbers or some information
like that, you should be able
to rationalize what might be
true about the rate of the
reaction. so, a large
activation energy means that
the rate constant is very
sensitive to changes
in temperature.
A large delta h means
equilibrium constant is very
sensitive to changes
in temperature.
And, as we've talked about, e
a is always positive, so the
elementary rates always increase
with temperature,
whereas delta h can be positive
or negative, so
equilibrium constants can
increase or decrease with
temperature.
And here, the magnitude of
delta h indicates the
magnitude of the change, how
much k will change, will it be
a big change or a small change,
whereas the sign of
delta h indicates the direction
of the change.
So, just want to review one
thing and then we'll
stop for the day.
So when a stress is applied to
a system, an equilibrium, the
system tends to try to
minimize that stress.
So we're back to LeChatelier's
principle.
And so, just one more clicker
question and we'll
stop for the day.
So increasing the temperature
is going to do what again?
Again, thinking back
to LeChatelier.
And just 10 more seconds.
Very good.
So, we're going to finish up
these notes on Monday.
We're going to think about
LeChatelier in a new way,
we're going to think about it in
terms of activation energy,
which is really fun, because we
tie back what we learned in
the middle of course to what
we're seeing now in the end of
the course.
All right, have a great
weekend, everybody.